non je ne suis pas favorable la
nationalisation des ehpad alors en ce
qui concerne le département de la vienne
c'est vrai qu'on a eu un certain nombre
d'établissements et résidences services
à l'époque qui étaient gérés par les
communes il était en très grande
difficulté financière et on a été
content de trouver ces grands groupes
qui avaient des moyens financiers
importants pour pour reprendre ces
établissements qui était qui était un
petit peu mieux la malle
vous parliez tout à l'heure de contrôler
conjointement avec l'agencé régionale de
santé et le département il nous faisons
des contrôles fréquents
avec des recommandations et surtout
ensuite des obligations dans le cas où
c'était où c'est vraiment nécessaire et
moi ce que je dirai ce qui serait
important c'est de proposer à ces
groupes de réinvestir ces capitaux sur
de réinvestir les bénéfices dans la
structure même
[Musique]